Have you ever wondered, why an actor didn't return for a sequel ?
Have you been disappointed when your favorite actor quit his starring role in a TV show?
Have you ever heard rumors about a movie production coming to a halt because an actor walked off the set?
Sometimes actors quit their jobs for pretty boring reasons,
But usually there is a juicy industry story behind it all.
Remember if you wanna see more lists like this,
Subscribe to our channel, and make sure to join our notification squad
"Hot damn almighty, I bet you're right"
But before we start, can you guess the movie from these emojis?
Stay tuned for the answer at the end of our video!
Keanu Reeves in Speed 2
A younger Keanu Reeves scored his first blockbuster hit in the 1995 action movie, Speed.
Playing a SWAT officer stuck on a Los Angeles bus that will explode if it goes below fifty miles an hour
If you are wondering how a sequel could be spun out of that idea, you're not the only one
*bus crash, explosions*
Both co-star Sandra Bullock and director Jean de Bont returned for the 1997 sequel
Speed 2 : Cruise Control
"This isn't happening."
Which essentially has the same plot but trades the bus for a boat
Reeves turned down the movie and his role was replaced by a new character played by Jason Patric.
"It's time to have a look at your face."
"Take off your mask."
"No."
James Purefoy in V for Vendetta
For their follow up to the Matrix series,
the Wachowskis recruited classically trained
English actor James Purefoy for the role of V,
a mass revolutionary in dystopian England
Six weeks into production, however, Purefoy dropped out with many scenes already filmed.
The Wachowskis and director James McTeigue quickly replaced him with Hugo Weaving
who they worked with on the Matrix.
"I wish there had been an easier way, but-"
Despite recasting the part, Purefoy can still be seen in much of the movie
but you won't be able to see his face or hear his voice
as he's wearing a Guy Fawkes mask and Weaving's voice is dubbed over his.
(Very robotic voice) "Hello there, children"
"How would you like some Salisbury steak?"
Isaac Hayes in South Park
In 2005 South Park released an episode in which they criticize the Church of Scientology
Isaac Hayes, a prominent Scientologist, criticized the episode and quit the series at the end of the season
For the premiere of the tenth season, Trey Parker and Matt Stone use old audio of Hayes
to bring back the character one last time...
Only to kill him in gruesome detail.
It may not have been the nicest way to go for a beloved character but
it certainly fit in with Parker and Stone's irreverent sense of humor
Michael Keaton in Batman Forever
After the smash success of Batman in
1989 Michael Keaton and director Tim
Burton returned for another go-around in
1992 s Batman Returns while successful
the darkly gothic returns didn't quite
reached the heights of its predecessor
so Warner Brothers decided to take the
franchise in a different direction and
brought on Joel Schumacher for 1995 s
Batman Forever
Keaton loyal to his friend Burton wanted
nothing to do with this film and turned
down a reported 15 million dollar payday
for the role this allowed Val Kilmer to
take over the role until he dropped out
of 1997 Batman and Robin and replaced by
George Clooney this Dog Show Dave
Chappelle Chappelle's Show
after years of toiling as a stand-up
comedian and supporting actor Dave
Chappelle finally hit the big time with
his own monster hit show on Comedy
Central the sketches on Chappelle's Show
steward topics like race gender politics
and the entertainment industry at large
after signing a 50 million dollar deal
for a third season however Chappelle
walked away after filming just three
episodes Chappelle cited the stress of
producing the series and return to stand
up after leaving the show after a few
down years Chappelle has recently teamed
up with Netflix for a series of stand-up
comedy specials jean-claude van damme
and creditor in 1987 the muscles from
Brussels jean-claude Van Damme was set
to star opposite Arnold Schwarzenegger
in the iconic film redditor but you
wouldn't have been able to see his face
- you see Van Damme was supposed to play
the predator himself wearing a costume
and a man apparently Van Damme didn't
like this idea so he dropped out of the
project leaving the role open for the
seven-foot - Kevin Peter Hall
I wouldn't prep too much Van Damme went
on to have a long and fruitful career
starring in movies like Timecop and
Universal Soldier so that's just alone
in Beverly Hills Cop - Eddie Murphy's
most iconic role is that of Detroit cop
actual Foley in the Beverly Hills Cop
series but believe it or not that role
is supposed to go to sylvester stallone
and you guys believe that when sly was
attached to the film it was more of a
straight-up action film but stallone
dropped out two weeks before filming was
set to begin and the producers needed a
replacement and fat they found that
replacement and up-and-coming comedian
Eddie Murphy who was hot off the success
of 48 hours in Trading Places and so the
script was rewritten as a comedy and
everything went forward without the
Italian stallion it don't matter who
went by an inch or a mile winnings women
Vin Diesel and too fast too furious and
xxx State of the Union in 2001 Vin
Diesel broke into the a-list with a
charismatic role as Dominic Toretto in
the street-racing thriller The Fast and
the Furious but instead of signing up
for the sequel diesel and director Rob
Cohen moved on to xxx and the only
successful action films without extreme
sports star turned spy Xander cage once
again however Diesel bowed out of the
sequel leaving his role of the Tyrese
Gibson and Ice Cube nevertheless
Diesel's career took a downward turn and
he found himself back in the Fast and
Furious fold for the fourth film of the
franchise earlier this year he also
returned to the xxx franchise with the
return of xander cage the most highly
anticipated film of 2004 if you try to
pull any Ferris Bueller Parent Trap
Three's Company FX FX - the deadly art
of Illusion bull I will beat you Chevy
Chase and community after a few years
out of the spotlight
former Saturday Night Live dropout Chevy
Chase returned to television and Dan
Harmon's community immediately chase
began to clash the showrunner Dan Harmon
after three seasons Sony fired Harman
disappointing fans of the series unique
voice never the
that wasn't enough to keep chase happy
as he walked off the set at the end of
the season this could be like scrub
season 9 a revamp do-over this allowed
Harmon to return for a much better
received fit season after chases
character was killed off of the series
Johan solo I used to be
Jefferson Ford in Star Wars The Force
awakens whoa whoa be careful before
watching the rest of this entry because
we're getting into spoilers for Star
Wars The Force awakens
Harrison Ford didn't walk off the set or
rip a contract didn't leave people
hanging or turned down a huge payday he
just wanted to die or more accurately he
wanted his character to die that's why
it Harrison Ford actually thought Han
Solo should have died in Return of the
Jedi but George Lucas
he wouldn't oblige him so he brought the
same request to JJ Abrams before making
the force awakens and this time he got
his wish that's where the heartbreaking
scene of Han Solo facing off against
kylo Ren came from and now we will never
see Han Solo in another Star Wars film
ever again
probably well that's our list for the
day but you're probably wondering the
answer to the emoji challenge is the
fast end of furious
did you notice the little car that was
the hint that's all for this list but be
sure to subscribe to the Screen Rant
channel and sign up for the notification
squad have a good day
you